my goal this year with the show is to
expand on even more topics we discuss as
well as the people that we're talking to
yes we absolutely hit our stride by
calling out regressive [ __ ] and by
addressing the regressives the tide is
actually turning people are finally
standing up to their insincere attacks
and realizing that liberalism is about
the rights of individuals before that of
the group so if you truly believe in
equality for women then you have to
defend their individual rights whether
it's to wear what they want drive a car
or marry who they choose regardless of
their religious or cultural background I
said there was an awakening months ago
and it's pretty undeniable right now
right that doesn't mean we can rest
though if anything it means we have to
dig in deeper and keep calling out
regressive nonsense when we see it
but as I've also said from day one I
want this show to be a place for big
ideas of all kinds over the course of
the next few weeks I'm going to talk to
people from hugely different walks of
life conservative radio talk show host
Larry elder science writer and skeptic
Michael Shermer and former leader of the
English Defence League
Tommy Robinson just to name a few we're
going to go big on topics ranging from
the election to science to spirituality
and more we're kicking off the year with
CNN's Don Lemon love him or hate him Don
is one of the few people in mainstream
media not afraid to say what he thinks
and he often pays for it via criticism
from both sides of the aisle not only
does he hosts his own nightly show but
he also reports on location from natural
disasters co-hosts electoral debates and
is even forged an unlikely friendship
with Glenn back along the way I know
when we see these people on TV we have a
way of thinking that they aren't even
human that they're just robots or
something but I can assure you from
personal experience that with Don what
you see is what you get
we can always mock mainstream media and
we absolutely should trust me I have
made plenty of jokes at CNN's expense
just check my Twitter feed at the same
time we should acknowledge though that
there are many journalists in the
mainstream media trying to do good work
while online media has changed the way
we get the news I think one of the big
lessons from 2015 is how online media
could also be full of
crap just because something isn't
mainstream doesn't mean it doesn't push
a narrative distort facts or outright
lie as 2016 begins let's all continue to
shed light on issues we care about talk
about difficult topics in an honest way
and see if we can make the conversations
in our lives a little more enlightened
all right my guest this week is the host
of CNN tonight self-proclaimed king of
Twitter and one of the few guys in cable
news not afraid to tell you what he
really thinks Don Lemon what's going on
it's called Cena tonight with Don Lemon
okay a with Don Lemon with Don limit how
long did you have to fight to get that
in there not that I'm picky
listen it's everything is important it
all matters Dave Rubin how are you I'm
doing good it actually it does all
matter and it's funny that you say that
because that I think that's a good place
to start because you have been on this
like upward thing forever we've known
each other for probably like four or
five years now and you did my old Sirius
XM show a long time ago and and you were
you were subbing in for a lot of people
you were jumping around show to show but
you have your own gig now pretty good
right it is pretty good I mean it's
weird because people say you've been on
this upward trajectory Volvo it doesn't
feel that way when you're living it
right I'm still the same guy um it still
feels the same and I'm still you know
the struggle is real right but it's
great to be in prime time on a major
network I mean you know you kind of it
doesn't get any better than this a show
with my name on it there I had no
complaints and very I live every moment
in gratitude right now yeah so there's
there's a lot of stuff I wanted to have
the first show of the year with you
because you're in the thick of it right
like every time I turn on the news and
something's going down somewhere they
send you there or you're at the studio
or you're interviewing somebody so I
thought you'd be the perfect person to
sort of kick the year off with but let's
get a little bit first what's like the
day-to-day operations so you have your
show at night what's going on in the in
the world of Don Lemon all day long well
it depends on it depends on the day but
I mean pretty much every night I'm on
the air at 10:00 p.m. and every night
between 7:00 and 8:00 I have a rundown
meeting and every single morning at
10:00
editorial meeting and then someday if
I'm up I try to do the network editorial
call at 9:00 so it can be a very long
day and then I do radio on some mornings
at 7:00 this is all Eastern Time
yeah about 7:00 7:15 Eastern Time so it
depends if it's a day I do radio I'm up
at 6:45 7 o'clock and I'm giving an
editorial on the time during the morning
show and then I try to read in from then
and reach the papers are at my door and
then I try to stay awake and if I do I
do
nine o'clock editorial call and if I
don't I wake up at 10:30 for my show's
editorial call and then I'll try to go
back to sleep but then sometimes other
shows will call and ask me to do live
shots to do something I cover the night
before I'm going to cover the that night
or I'll do an interview with Donald
Trump or coming into a taping like I did
a date with Rand Paul it just really
depends so there's no set schedule so
sometimes I get to sleep other times I
don't and that's it and so you said
usually I'm here I try to be unless I
don't have any sleep out the latest I'll
get in is probably like 6:00 or 6:30
yeah but usually I try to get in about
4:00 or 4:30 and you're taking you're
taking naps in that is your office right
there I saw you lets you blanket so you
do take that out just before you just
before we hooked up on skype yeah we
connected on skype be careful be careful
on the couch and by you know crystal
right I do yeah crystal came in and said
hey what you doing don't go to sleep you
got a Skype with Dave Rubin in 15
minutes I'm like I know I know date
he'll be fine I'll be fine you know it's
funny even the way that you started
saying hook up there and then you
immediately have to hedge your bets
because you're one of these people and I
want to talk about this a little later
on that everything that you say becomes
like this sort of hot-button thing but
before we before we delve into all that
stuff how much news do you actually have
to consume every day because I know I do
an interview show once a week but I'm in
the news constantly I'm always paying
attention to this stuff and on Twitter
and doing this whole thing and there's a
certain amount of bandwidth I think that
you only have in your brain to absorb
all this stuff but you have to know sort
of all the stuff that's going on all the
time
that's a very good point um and
sometimes I can because I consume so
much that I forget right like oh yeah I
knew that like someone will say
something and I'll go yeah that's right
I knew like like today I was sent out a
note on Wayne LaPierre
flip-flop on background checks yeah then
someone else reminded me that we did it
before and I'm like oh yeah that's right
we did do that before and then and I
looked up why he did it so there's a you
know he has a perfectly legitimate
explanation and he said why he did it
but sometimes you just forget so um what
I try to do quite honestly is not to UM
I try to be informed without being
inundated mm-hmm because you don't have
to know every single thing that's going
on in the world and I don't my show
doesn't cover every single thing that's
going on in the world I don't do it a
traditional rundown news show like stack
like now this now this now this it's
pretty much a theme and it is the
biggest story of the day or the hottest
topic or the talker of the day and
usually we try not to do too many
subjects where we try to make them all
relate and we don't do a lot of stars
like traditionally you know when Piers
was here and when Larry was here the
hours that I'm in now were like very
star heavy and focus and they didn't do
very well and so we do water cooler talk
provocative conversation have
conversations that people will have at
home but not necessarily on television
and it's paid off and thank goodness our
ratings are great we're doing great and
you know we're still going yeah how much
of that comes directly from you because
I remember when when you did my show way
back when whatever that was four or five
years ago I think that same week that we
met you had subbed in for Joy Behar over
on HLN and I remember we were having a
drink and you were saying how much you
liked that because it gave you a chance
to sort of be yourself and get out of
the kind of traditional newsman thing so
all these decisions in terms of the
format and all that is that all coming
directly from you well I did shared a
lot of it comes from me and a lot of it
comes from the the team our staff the
producers and our executive producer
Jonathan wall who's really great with
ideas and then I'll have ideas as well
it depends on the day sometimes like now
you know it's a no-brainer the president
has had
this big Town Hall with Anderson this
young he may he did the sing at the
White House we're going to talk about
guns right we're going to talk about
executive orders and and so it's that's
pretty easy we're going to talk about
what's happening in Oregon so sometimes
it's just pretty self-explanatory it's
our show it's great to finally have a
show and that I don't have to call a
newscast because it's not a newscast
although when it needs to be we can
quickly become a newscaster on that we
can give you I can give you the 30
second or 15 second elevator pitch
between one floor biggest story of the
day or biggest talkers otherwise it does
not fit I don't care if you're a movie
star I don't care who you are if it's
not if it has nothing to do with the
news if it's not relevant it's not
coming on the show yeah that simple all
right so before we get into all the meat
and we're going to talk politics and
guns and all that kind of stuff how did
you get into this thing did you always
want to be on TV did you always want to
be a news guy what brought little Don
Lemon to be over at Time Warner Center
right now I was always curious as a kid
and um when I we would go out and about
my parents I write about this in my book
which is called transparent by the way
yeah that I would just talk to everybody
and you know my mom would like come and
grab me in the restaurant my dad would
always say don't teach him to be afraid
of people and my mom said after that
conversation she'd just let me go
so I would just ask people like what do
you hear you're on vacation what you're
doing I've just always been curious I
don't necessarily think that I wanted to
be on television although I liked it um
I always wanted to be a journalist and
you know people remind me when I go home
for holidays we just visit my family
that you remember you're in college used
to bring the camera to school remember
we tape this fake show when you were kid
you remember used to carry this camera
around and then or do you remember we
had you anchor our high school and so I
forgot a lot of those things and so it's
always been there yeah so let's talk
about the gay thing for just a sec
because I don't think we I don't know
about you let's talk about your gay
thing for a second we can talk about
mine too if you want um there's so much
I can go cuz it let me see that hand
raise your left hand oh yeah I got one
of these Wow
I got one of these yeah
that's okay go ahead you you can get one
too I know didn't you just say I think
if I'm not mistaken just on air a couple
days ago you said to somebody why would
you get married didn't you say that to
Brooke or somebody Oh somebody in the
crowd why would you get married I just
think that no I I don't want to create
another controversy yeah I don't see the
need to run off and get married right oh
right away or ever and I don't know if
I'm the marrying kind
yeah that listen my whole thing and I'm
pretty sure you'll agree with me on this
is that we should just have the right
the same right that everybody else has
salutely yeah if you want to do it do it
if you don't want to do it don't do it
like that's it but that's why I don't
even want to talk about the gay thing
much so we could literally do just a
minute on this but I know I'm just
messing with you because we know each
other no no I know but like I to me like
and we've talked about this privately
but like it's exhausting talking about
the gay thing gay people shouldn't have
to think about it any more than straight
people should have to think about their
sexuality or any of that but anyway you
basically came out when your book came
out so it's about four years ago is that
right
okay mr. Phil Emily 20 I was 2011 it was
funny because I was talking to a friend
in Chicago which was before I came to
work at CNN and he said because I know
people were saying Don Lemon came out
and he's like what do you mean darling
it came out Don Lemon has always been
out yeah so I you know since I've been
out since my 20s but it wasn't something
that I talked about on the air or shared
publicly but my bosses knew I would
bring my boyfriends to the Christmas
party I mean it wasn't a big deal but
the public didn't know I would host
events for like gay events in Chicago
and now he shows basically out so when
people say you know it took you 45 years
to come out I'm like well not really I I
think I had to do it because there was
so much confusion and when you're in the
public eye I think it's important that
you say at least when I came out that
you sort of you had to make a
declaration because it's important for
young people who are at home people who
may be struggling people who may have
doubt and I want people to know like hey
you can be a gay person and you can host
a show on CNN and it is okay yes so
that's the part that I wanted to talk
about because this is exactly what we
talked about four years ago that there
was so much going on with gay rights
there was so much happening at the
moment and in a way as a public person
it's sort of you had like this extra
pressure of if I'm going to talk about
this on air I have to be authentic about
it right like how much of that did you
actually really feel well I no one
forced me I started writing a book about
you know sort of my exploits as a
journalist and writing about my
childhood and you know how I grew up and
whatever and I just thought it would be
disingenuous to write a book like that
and not included so it's like you know
telling everything about your life
except for that you know one important
thing that what that one thing that is
really important it's not all of who I
am um but it is an important part of my
life and I think it's important again
for other people to be able to see
someone like me or like a Dave Rubin who
people who are successful and who just
happened to be gay so yeah there was a
lot of pressure on it on me and there
was a lot of pressure to as a person of
color to come out yeah isn't it cool how
it's so irrelevant I mean that's even
why I'm preface Ingush by saying let's
just run over to second yeah listen let
me tell you it's irrelevant to you and
it's relevant to many people who live in
big cities like you're in LA now I'm in
New York and we met with you and in New
York um so it for us it's easy because
there I am there is no space place where
I am in the closet my entire team knows
the audience knows my family knows
people at the barbershop know like I
don't really care what you know Bob at
the barbershop thinks about me or the
gay people
yes it's I'm I am completely out and
that is to a lot of people that's not
reality and it's strange to certain
people especially certain demographics
and certain ethnicities people aren't
quite that out yet it I think it's
easier for you as a white man to be out
yeah all right well okay so we'll delve
into some of the racial stuff so my last
thing on the gay thing is do you think
there is something about gay people in
general that there are so many out gay
people in news right now I mean you take
you and you take Cheevers and Anderson
and Rachel Maddow and Thomas Roberts and
and you know there's a half out guy on
Fox even he may be out already I'm not
sure I'm not even gonna name of who you
talk you don't even have to smile or
look at the camera or whatever but my
point is that for some reason you know
Riley yeah he's definitely gay that guy
ya know but you stole my point that
there's a lot of out people that people
get there there's something comforting
in a weird way or something
about gay people it would be anything
there yes there's something comforting
about gay people we're loving people
we're allowing ABBA
but here's the thing I don't think Dave
that those numbers are any different
than any other profession I think that
there have been some people who are
brave enough to step up in this
profession because I feel that if you're
a journalist you take an oath much like
you do if you have a juris doctorate
when you become an attorney if you have
it when you you know you take the
medical oath when you become a doctor I
think that journalists really feel that
you know you have an obligation to
inform people you have an obligation to
tell the truth you have an obligation to
be as unbiased and objective as any
human being can be so I think that when
you're in this business in order to get
the truth from people in order to be
truthful you have to live who you are
and if you can't put different rules on
other people that you put on yourself
and so I think that maybe people are
just more visible because it's a visible
medium obviously and I just think that
you know we sort of take that oath but I
don't I think there are plenty of gay
doctors there are plenty of gay lawyers
or plenty of gay politicians as we have
seen there plenty of gay people in the
clergy and on on and on I don't think
it's any different I just think that we
happen to be more visible for the record
I have a friend who's a gay janitor so
we are out we're in every occupation
that there is I know gay athletes I know
gay
everything yeah so there you go all
right so that's it for the gay thing
forget about that let's move on let's
all right so cable news like you want me
you got a ring on your finger stop it
with me it's enough already
um so cable news what do you make of the
general state of cable news because it
gets a lot of crap at you know from
everybody all the time and I'm not
talking about you specifically but in
general you say cable news and people
start freaking out right so what do you
make of the general like sense of cable
news well I think it's you know
obviously it's an easy target right the
media excuse me the media is always an
easy target and so when you're in that
easy target that happens to be on 24
hours a day you're going to be an even
bigger target and when you're on and
there's no script there you know then
you're an even bigger target
because we are human and sometimes many
times most times there are no words in
that box to read when you're in cable
now if you're on broadcast it's a whole
different story if you're doing an
evening broadcast in national or local
everything is scripted for you you read
if you're doing a 30-minute newscast
maybe you read at the most five to seven
minutes of copy right you're saying oh
the big story out west is the flooding
another about dave rubin joins us with
the latest dave what do you know boom
and then that's it and you go thank you
Dave and now let's talk about the
presidents you know reform on gun
control and you even talk like this it's
a very specific way that you have to
hurts or for you in bubble wine all
you're saying is thank you and the most
that you'll say is incredible report Bob
Wow that's it or on your table you're
saying no listen that's not right the
facts aren't there hold on let me get my
information where the president said
back inside your such--such and other
people are screaming right then you're
like wait wait now you talk wait wait
now you talk yeah there's a lot more
room for error
there's a lot more people talking back
and forth it's a lot more interesting to
watch so of course people are gonna you
know we're gonna be a target and
sometimes is early so most of the time
not really because we're just we're just
we just happen to be on television in
very real moments a lot of the time yeah
so to that point how often because I
right now in this very second I have an
IFB in my ear just so that I can hear
you because it's the nature of how we're
doing Skype I think I don't think you
have one in right here you're just doing
the Skype off the computer but one other
thing yeah they're okay we have proof
but one of the things I hear all the
time and I think I probably thought this
too is that when you're on cable news
you're on television in general there's
someone in your ear always barking
orders at you how often is that actually
true for you that that you're doing your
broadcast and someone is actually
telling you what to say and I'm not
talking about the technical stuff cut to
commercial I mean you know well
sometimes we sometimes people tell you
what to say and sometimes you look a man
thank you
sometimes people are correcting you yeah
some people are like they're your other
ears they're listening to the guests and
the someone will say well you know well
it's gonna it's gonna affect the Fourth
Amendment
and then some the producer will say the
president never mentioned the 4th
amendment and you'll say hey listen the
president never mentioned the fourth
amendment right
sometimes you'll say um it was a an
unalienable right and then the producer
will say inalienable right so do their
little things or um I always like to
tell people that both this recent
example is we go on the air everything
is ready
in the show you know the open is
scripted right and it's like you know
bah bah bah I don't swamp ass at a rally
and Iowa this is CNN tonight I'm Don
Lemon right and then all of a sudden
that you know introduced now let's go to
our panel Dave Rubin is here Ryan liz is
here and you know Kayleigh mcenany's
here so panel and then someone will say
stop and I'll go oh stand by yeah I'll
say and then they'll roll the breaking
news animation you're like oh okay and
they'll go breaking news and you go
breaking news and they'll say there's
been a plane that's been diverted you
say there's been a plane that's been
diverted and then as you're talking
they'll say okay now go with prompter
and so all of this stuff you're talking
and then you look up and they say okay
joining us on the phone and they'll say
Bob Williams so say Bob Williams from
nebraska from nebraska and so you you
know and sometimes you'll be in the
middle of a sentence and people will
talk to you so it does happen people at
home think you're stupid but actually
you're not that stupid you're just like
well what uh so that's it
and that's why I wanted to ask you that
because I think there's this sense out
there that you're getting orders of what
you can and should say and and what
you're really saying is it's technical
stuff it's stuff because we're we have a
live program and maybe they're
fact-checking you but they're not being
like Don you better really you or I'm
saving you by we will explain what you
meant by that you're like oh oh what I
meant was because some someone might
misconstrue it but it doesn't really
everything it's misconstrued and
everything now gets taken out of context
like I can say okay look Dave let's not
talk about the gay thing right and then
so we'll just take that and say oh don
Lemmons ashamed of being gay and you're
like no that was like a half a sentence
in an entire conversation that we had
and then it builds upon itself and it
keeps building it's like a wildfire and
by the time it gets to the end it has
absolutely nothing to do with what you
said and then people believe it
because of social media it's really kind
of ridiculous I want to explore that
somehow yeah we should investigate that
well it's something that we've been
talking about here a lot because one of
the things that I'm seeing all the time
now and unfortunately I see this more on
the left is people being misquoted all
the time and no matter what you say and
and so that it's a good segue actually
because I think you in terms of the
mainstream media people you're the
victim of this all the time I mean every
time I open up mediate Don Lemon says
this Don Lemon this that Don Lemon you
ever go back and look at the whole thing
of what I said you were like wait a
minute that's not what happened at all
well Don I don't have that kind of time
to listen for context I've got me what
do you and I have things to do but but
that's exactly what your point is that
they get you on the on the one-liner
they know that nobody's gonna go back
and you know watch the two minutes
before the two minutes after so for you
how how aware of that do you have to be
and how much are you thinking the whole
time I better not go there even though
it's what I really believe or it's how
you know what I want to say well I'm
aware a little bit but um I can't do
that to myself I don't want to censor
myself that way because then you're not
authentic and I think that you know
whatever success I've achieved I think
it's been through authenticity and so if
I was worried about every single word
and how it's going to be of course you
want to be smart right and you want to
be buttoned up in a certain way or have
your facts straight I don't want to do
that and so if you want to take me out
of context and that's your business
and I think for the most part smart
people the viewers aren't dumb they
understand what's happening and this
stuff that happens online especially
like Twitter and all those it doesn't
usually translate to television it
certainly doesn't translate into ratings
um and it doesn't translate into
credibility so you know you just it's
wonderful that I work for a network and
a boss who says constantly ignore the
noise you guys are doing great the
network is doing great
our story is great right now continue
the momentum be yourself be smart keep
moving and don't even read doesn't even
matter if we tweet or not or we don't
have to read it it's a it's amazing and
wonderful we're in a great spot right
now on seeing it so we don't worry about
that kind right it's kind of funny
because
the social media side you know like I
could pick something like when you said
the the black hole thing during the the
plane thing and you know you you're on
air for hours you're talking about all
of this stuff you're just throwing out
you know somebody said it could be a
black hole like you weren't saying it's
in a black hole or what like whatever it
is and then next thing you know Don
Lemon is trending and all that so you
really you really can just put it aside
no I mean I can because we listen we
I've talked about this ad nauseam the
New York Times did a thing on it it's at
it's not that you believe those things
we had a thing called crazy conspiracy
theories that people were sending to us
yeah so one of those was that it was a
question from a viewer that's it I read
the question from a viewer and that was
the end of story and that took on a life
of its own but so be it it made me
famous but it's not enough
this review this is what viewers are
saying they were also saying it was in a
hangar somewhere that we mentioned that
they were also saying that it was it was
flown someone else took it and hijacked
it there were a number of different
things that were said about it all of
which we talked about on social media
that one just happened to get picked up
yeah you know at the top of the show I
did a little piece on how I was saying
we need mainstream media but we also
need online media because I do believe
we need both for different reasons and
different corporate interests and all
that I think I think I think we look as
the online guy in the mainstream guy
more we need more honest online people
we need online people online people who
will actually do their homework who will
call who will not write an article off
of someone else's article or off of
someone else's opinion of what someone
else did online people who actually saw
the entire segment in context to do
their job not just like lazy people are
lazy and they just go oh you know I'm
such-and-such whatever yeah he said that
and you're like no that's not so it's
and it's kind of hard for us for those
of us who are in more traditional media
to chase all of those things down and
it's just not worth it yeah I mean you
literally took the words out of my mouth
that's exactly as I say because I think
at some point there was the online media
did was doing a lot of good stuff
getting to stories that maybe hadn't
bubbled up to you guys yet and yet
somehow in the last year or two there's
so many trashy
sites that are just waiting for you for
not not just the you know the on-air
guys but for politicians to just find
any little thing that they can say and
run with that just so that they can get
clicks and they're no longer doing a
service either it's what we call it
click click bait
so I we're at the point here at CNN
where we realize that I'm click bait so
just say Donlan and people are gonna
click on it yeah so they will say Don
Lemon and then anything but um what I
wanted to say is oh when you talk about
online people so have you ever worked
for a traditional network where you work
for Sirius so that was I would imagine
that's pretty yeah that was corporate
that was corporate is so rigorous here
before I could say anything on the air
as a fact or you know present something
it's got to go through our fact checkers
as it has to go through standards and
practices you know what our definition
of we're talking about the guys in
Oregon what our definition of terrorism
is all of those things on how we confirm
things we had we the other night when
Natalie Cole died everyone was reporting
Natalie Cole died but we couldn't get in
touch with her
her publicist because the publicist was
busy and every time we call the phone
was busy the email I guess right we
could not report that CNN would not
report that until we heard from an
official person online people don't have
those you know they don't have to climb
those hurdles and I think that's sad and
missing because listen we don't have to
be first we just want to be accurate and
I wish like I wish the online people
want it to be more accurate than first
or funny or opinionated yeah I totally
hear you I feel like I sort of exist in
between those two worlds and I'm just
trying to do what you're saying which is
which is be honest and have honest
conversations and even though I have one
of these things in my ear nobody's
yelling what do they talk you know
they're nothing they're saying do it
you're doing a hell of a job that's what
they just said um so so the other thing
that I think is interesting about you is
that you get heat from both sides and
I'm not talking about when they misquote
you now I'm talking about if you say
something for example about black lives
matter are you taking a selfie right now
I just wanted this for I'm gonna do when
I when I post online
go ahead nice so that you get equal heat
from both sides so it can take a black
lives matter for example there's a
certain amount of racist people
we'll look at you as a as a black man
and just they're going to just say
racist [ __ ] it's just going to come no
matter what and then there'll be people
when you've said things that haven't
been you know sort of in lockstep with
with the movement that'll say you're an
Uncle Tom and I'm only using that word
because when I googled you it was one of
the first words that came up that Don
Lemon is a trademark that word go ahead
yeah that Don Lemon is an Uncle Tom but
to me it seems like you're usually doing
good stuff when people on both sides are
attacking you and that's what you're
getting all the time right well yes and
the thing that people here's the thing
that when I when we talk about double
standards and expectations of people as
a person of color well someone just to
say someone not of color people don't
expect you to be the spokesman for all
white men right or all my god
yeah right they don't even expect you to
be the spokesman for gay people thank
God well somehow there's this
expectation of me to be the spokesman
for black people or gay people and I am
neither what I am the spokesman for is
information and truth and so if black
lives matter does something that is
worthy of criticism then it is my job as
a journalist to give that criticism
mm-hmm because no movement is perfect
even the civil rights movement wasn't
perfect and received its share of
criticism so there's a black person in
this position the only one who is in
primetime on a cable network when people
see that coming from me they're like how
dare well I'm not daring I'm doing my
job
that is what I'm supposed to do so and
if someone who is why it sees me talking
about black lives matter and in a way
that's positive then of course I agree
with them yeah so you know I can't win
and so the point is not to be an
advocate or um someone who is you know
an activist my point is to be a
journalist yeah I get those races like
if there's homophobia I get there sexism
but at the end of the day what I'm
giving is information or if I say um you
know I just received information that
you know my co that the cop in the
Michael Brown case is not going to be
indicted that word is going to come out
people who want him to be indicted are
going to get upset and call me an Uncle
Tom because it came out of my mouth
and then 20 minutes later when the guy
comes out and says there's no indictment
no one goes oh he was right they just go
oh he's covering that story I can't
believe him you know so it's just it is
what it is people take out their
frustrations on the person who is in
front of them and I haven't eat that
person and do you find that a lot of it
it's odd that like with the Uncle Tom
stuff that that comes from people on the
left that they would want you right the
people on the Left they should see you
as an individual accept what they're
seeing or what they're complaining about
is that you should be this
representative of black America or
whatever I also find that the people who
are supposed to be the most tolerant are
the least because they they never
consider that they in fact may not be
because they think that everyone thinks
like them yeah and not everybody thinks
like you so you know concern I find that
listen I get it from all sides but I
find that the people who are most
incredulous about things and many times
the most vocal are liberals yeah yeah
and and many times for me as well
African Americans because they were
looking at me regardless of the facts
even if the facts don't pan out even if
the evidence and all the investigations
and all the autopsies show no hands up
don't shoot I have to come on television
and say hands up don't shoot I can't do
that that's not what the evidence shows
so I have to say the evidence does not
show that so that never happened
according to the evidence I can't
believe you you sell out any like Wong I
what do you want me to do lie I can't
lie right and then that's exactly where
they go oh it's because he's getting the
information from his ear which I think
you've Illustrated is actually not the
case okay so a lot of people have been
asking me this on Twitter and I thought
you'd be the perfect person to pose this
question to the way the media frames
certain things so the way the media
frames black lives matter versus how the
media is now framing this Oregon militia
thing and we don't have to get into the
Nitty Gritty of every little instance
that's happening but a lot of people
were saying you know that the media is
not calling these Oregon people they're
not calling them terror
and if this was a group of black people
or especially if this was a group of
Muslim people we would be calling them
terrorists and I I was googling the word
terrorism and you know it talks about
intimidation or violence not and
violence and to me it's a little hazy
whether them taking this building where
they had to use no force per se and but
you know apparently the building was
just open and yes they had guns in its
federal property and so whether it's
actually terrorism and would the media
be treating it differently if it was
either black people or Muslim you know
why are you falling into that trap David
I tell you what he'll be out of this
trap how about that so here's the thing
so I actually wrote an editorial saying
that it was terrorist in my editorial
for the Tom Joyner Morning Show and so
um you know it was read by someone here
at CNN and they said well our definition
of terrorism here at CNN is different is
that it has to be political it is
political that's political it also has
to have someone who has been hurt by it
uh like physically hurt so it's not
terrorism until someone is actually hurt
or killed or what-have-you and I think
that's part of the definition here but
according to the law enforcement people
I spoke to if you are doing something
for a political end or whatever that is
illegal in that manner than it is
terrorism so I have called it terrorism
I've heard other people call it
terrorism I don't know how other media
organizations frame it but here at CNN I
don't think there is a double standard
about what's going on and what it is now
here's the thing is it do I know that it
you know would it be different if it was
Muslims or if it was black black people
yeah of course I live in America I know
that in this particular case so I have
to have to hedge it and say I'm not so
sure and here's why because it is in the
middle of nowhere
it's 280 miles from Portland Oregon the
big next biggest city burns is what 80
or 30 or 80 miles away and no one really
knows where burns Oregon is right so it
is basically a truck stop not even a
truck stop and a rest stop in the middle
of nowhere what the government is trying
to do the FBI is trying to do is to
avoid another Ruby Ridge and another
wake up yeah and so it is the middle of
winter
nobody's there nobody is in danger of
being heard the best thing that these
guys can do is be ignored I hate that we
even have to give them media attention
because they're Yahoo's they're not
within their legal right for anything so
I think what they're doing now is
perfectly fine let them sit there in the
middle of winter and freeze their asses
off and fine if you want to stay down in
the middle of winter in that little
crappy building then that is your
business yes it is a federal building
and they are breaking the law and at
some point they will have to take care
of it but I think at this point I think
they're actually doing the right thing
as far as a media reaction I don't I
haven't seen any I don't know anyone
who's called it like a peaceful protest
or what-have-you
it is what it is it's um people who are
ignorant of the law who have taken over
a building and they should pay for the
pay the consequences when the time comes
but right now I say ignore them yeah and
I'm pretty sure they're not gonna get
what they want at the end of this
they're not that's usually just half of
these things I am and it's many of the
people whose land was saved by the
government helping them out years ago
yeah now they want to reclaim it and get
the money back that they're more money
than was already given to them they're
just ignorant of the law if this was a
building that mattered in the middle of
a city that mattered
sure reaction would be completely
different yeah and there would be more
direct threat to don't be more of a
direct threat yes but I do think that
they're getting a pass there because of
their religion they're not Muslim
because they're you know white not
African American I do but I don't know
how different the reaction would really
be I don't know because it's a building
that nobody cares about in a city in a
place that nobody really cares about
yeah yeah and it's only 15 about 15 or
so people who are actually in that
building it's not hundreds of people
yeah they're running out of snacks I
heard so this thing can't last that long
they're idiots all right so let's talk
about some of the things that bring us
together because that you know what the
audience is gonna go nasty lemons
looking at somebody who's giving him the
signal whether he could talk about it or
not someone is in my office but I'm just
birches laughing yeah um so one thing
that you've done that I really
appreciate because it comes completely
with the spirit of how I've done this
show is you've really tried to build
bridges with people that /
some might think you shouldn't get along
with or you shouldn't talk with so I've
seen you a couple times with Glenn Beck
and and I was tweeting up a storm the
first time I saw it because I thought
this is exactly what the news is
supposed to be this is what not not
reporting but this is what conversation
is supposed to be you guys come from
very different places you know he's a
pure libertarian I suppose your politics
are different and you know you're just
trying to have the conversation and
that's what I'm trying to do here and I
thought it was pretty beautiful I was oh
I guess I don't even know if my question
is as much as I want to see more of that
well he say that our politics are
different I'm not political I'm like the
least political person that you know I'm
come on I swear I don't care about
conservative or liberal I think all
politicians are full of it I think but
I'll go with the other and I judge
things on my own
so you know especially coming from an
African American background African
Americans are pretty liberal and some
things and also very conservative and
many times conservative socially when it
comes to the church yeah so you know you
know for people to sit there and pretend
like oh where are those big liberals and
they're not and then you don't accept
gay people and then it's oh it's it's
not true so I'm not I I am NOT political
so when you say my politics are
different it's not I will listen I think
the only way especially if it's someone
you don't agree with or if you consider
them your enemy or not on your side
don't you want to know what they're
thinking
I don't understand what people say I am
never gonna talk to them how could you
don't you dare sit down you know how
much crap I got because I like I because
I sat down twice valia Aaron Wilson and
I went um I almost got the interviews
between me uh George Stephanopoulos and
one other person I forget who it was and
we all we almost you know George ended
up getting the interview I got so much
guff because I wanted to do an interview
with him it's like what don't you want
to hear from him Nick even if you don't
agree with him especially if you don't
agree with him you want to hear his
rationale and his reasoning so it has
never made sense to me to UM not talk to
someone who you disagree with now
that said I think that people should be
respectful and they should be in their
right minds you know before you or when
you're talking to them and if they don't
then they're out of here I'll cut you
right off yeah yeah if you're being an
ignoramus I'm not dealing with it yeah
well interestingly I wasn't even gonna
bring this up but a couple months ago
maybe two months ago or so you had Sam
Harris who's been on my show who's
become a friend of mine and Dean
Obeidallah were on and they were they
were debating this Islam and sort of you
know religion verse people thing and in
the midst of it Dean said something that
I knew to be a you know implying that
Sam believed something about all Muslims
and I knew it to be not true because I
had sat there with Sam and rehashed it
he's rehash it a thousand times and
while it was infuriating for me to watch
I thought all right at least they're
having the conversation so that's what
you're just opening the door for yeah
and the the thing about that is is that
we have to stop calling people you know
isms or phobias phobias homophobic or
Islamophobic whatever because they want
to have a conversation that's part
that's what we do yeah is have a
conversation and when you have great
minds like you know a free Zakaria or
Sam Harris or whomever who say yes there
is a problem that must be addressed in
Islam and we have to figure out how to
do it when you have great minds like
that those are the people that you
should listen to when you get people who
say there is no problem and by you
saying this then you are Islamophobic
them that person is very dangerous
because the evidence is there doesn't
mean that people in that religion or
that it doesn't mean that it that Islam
is bad doesn't mean that Muslims are bad
doesn't mean that because we talk about
crime in Chicago that is committed
mostly by african-americans it doesn't
mean that african-americans are bad or
that black people are bad it means that
we're just having those conversations
and so um we have to stop that and you
know that's I think that's why I can
talk to someone like a Glenn Beck is
because you know I want to I would
rather have common ground with people or
try to reach some sort of common ground
or consensus rather than just having
them an enemy keeping them at arm's
length and not being at the table that's
what's happening in Washington and
with the Congress right now what good is
that doing anybody yeah so that's
actually a perfect segue for the
political climate so let's just talk
about that a little bit so you've been
in this for a while it's pretty bad
right now right like could it get much
worse I keep thinking that it's not
going to get much worse and now I
realize we're in an election year we've
got this crazy thing with Trump right
now that's me yeah you just have to nod
through this whole thing probably but
really like how much worse is this thing
going to get before this election comes
I think it's going to get a lot worse
and I think because of how much is being
amped up on both sides so whoever's in
the White House next is going to have a
huge challenge like if a Democrat is in
there all those people that have been
revved up by the right and by Donald
Trump they're like some people you can't
you just go Hillary Clinton go ah her
name right yeah same thing you say
Donald Trump big oh my god I hate that
guy
you can't even get their name out so I
think people are becoming amped up more
than almost any election that I've seen
except for during the Obama election it
was pretty it was pretty crazy right him
and Sarah Palin it was like wow what in
a weird way doesn't it seem like to me
it seems like we were all on ecstasy
back then like it was like said besides
the past is that it we just romanticized
the past it was bad yeah I mean come on
it was you know he wasn't he wasn't
America and he was a Muslim he went to a
madrasah um what else oh you know air
socialist or a socialist all those
things and then you know McCain couldn't
find a running mate and then he found
Sarah Palin and that was a disaster and
then people said oh my god everybody was
out to get Sarah Palin and then as it
turns out she was not as informed as she
should have been and so it was you know
it was a little crazy right all that
said we didn't have a trump right how do
you deal with this Trump thing because
one of the things that I've noticed and
we've talked about a bunch I makes me I
love interviewing if you love it I know
I don't necessarily love what he says
that's not don't get me wrong
ya know but the love is a spectacle I
love know know I love interviewing
because you don't know what he's going
to say I love the back-and-forth I love
the way his mind works
doesn't mean I agree with him and you
know when he's like excuse me excuse me
done you know people at home are like oh
you cut you off inside I'm kind of
laughing I'm like my gosh and I'm like
hey you know when he goes ah excuse me
done he it's it's a bit comical
sometimes he's a performer so I love
interviewing him but that's about it
so is that really though the secret
sauce to what he's doing that the rest
of these guys all of them pretty much I
would argue that Bernie probably is not
because Bernie does seem like he's
speaking from the heart and he speaks in
a way that doesn't sound like a
politician but pretty much the rest of
them they all just sound like
politicians and people are over that and
and because of that even when Trump says
crazy stuff it makes people like him
like there's where we have this like
Bing that's like eating itself
constantly with him and because of that
I mean I tell people this cuz it usually
ticked them off right I usually tell
like people who are on the Left
President Trump get used to annoying oh
but it's you know I had never I had not
underestimated him since he got into the
race because here's why and I said this
from the beginning you can probably find
it on tape somewhere he's used to
swimming in these New York media waters
sharks right he knows how to handle
manipulate the media he knows how to cut
a deal you know if you can when they say
if you can make it there you can make it
anywhere this guy's made it I help from
his dad don't get me wrong but you know
he um he's made it here he's become you
know at the top of the sort of food
chain and the media food chain here he
knows how to deal with the media and so
and he's got a lot of money a lot of it
of running for president is having a ton
of dough and he has a ton of dough and
he knows how to deal with people and he
has a good ear on what people want to
hear so when he's in front of a crowd
he's like oh they like that huh he gets
him boy oh they don't like that so much
he changes the subject so having known
all of that and being here in the 90s
and and knowing Donald Trump was like
this guy isn't going anywhere so yeah
yeah all right I got just a couple more
for you because I know you have to
keep on y'all your you have to be live
on air not too not too long from now and
about in two hours and oh I got plenty
I'll go listen I'll talk as long as you
want to um uh how much do you think I'm
one of my major issues is when I watch
something on live by the way no we're
not like we're done when I watch
something like the you know the Press
Club the yearly thing where the media
gets together and roasts the politicians
and all it what's it called at the Press
Club the White House correspondent White
House Correspondents Dinner thanks when
I watch all of this stuff and even I saw
you a couple weeks ago at the in the
spin room at the debate in Vegas we were
at the democratic debate there and I've
been around it a little more lately one
of the things that I really do fear is
that the the media and the politicians
are just in it too tightly that people
are just too friendly with each other
they're actually you know they're we
have so many instances of people that
are married to people on television and
they're the kids at this one or the
uncle of that one on all of this stuff
I'm pretty sure you're no one in your
families pulling strings in politics
right let's get that out of the way
except for my cousin broad but that's
great of course he's your cousin of
course these you guys right but really
how do you see that as an actual threat
to democracy because that I really see
as a major problem oh I don't know if I
would call it a threat to democracy I do
see it as um it's a little fake and
phony to me but you know it was great
going to you know being invited to the
White House correspondent Center but it
was a lot more fun when I was covering
and I can make fun of people right so
how much does that make you bite your
tongue cuz you want to go to the dinners
right like we've all been around okay
good person I went to the White House
Christmas party right and because I knew
the Obamas from Chicago and it was it's
tough and I've said this before like
when you know someone people I didn't
know them that well they weren't my best
friends but I knew them from around the
way right from being I was a local news
anchor and they were there you know that
I would introduce the met you know
chicken dinners like you know State
Senator Barack Obama I'm sure and then
then his wife would always say Oh Don
stay out of trouble and I'm like who me
why so to have to sort of criticize him
on policy and things it was at first it
was uncomfortable to Michael he's the
president and the buck stops with him so
I've got it you know and he's black
whatever I've got to do it I'm a
journalist that was I I took a note and
so when I saw him sort of in an informal
context and not like throwing questions
at him or seeing him at NABJ and like
yelling across the room like how are you
gonna handle this and having him yell
back when I had to go and like shake
their hand and take a picture with him I
was like ooh what are they gonna say it
so I walked up and you know and they
were like hey you know you did the right
thing by coming out and I was like thank
you right and so they get it they get it
but it was a little weird and I felt
like I don't know if I should be that
close to when in this sort of situation
to be partying with the president or for
that matter partying with some of the
people you know when you go to the
Oscars and all those things I don't know
I just feel like I kind of feel like
Wendy Williams right who sits in her
purple chair and she like talks smack
about everybody and then when they see
her or when she sees it she's like oh I
kind of feel like that a little bit so
yeah but don't you think don't you think
that more you guys need that sense
because I totally feel like everybody
you know and it's not just I don't mean
just at the friendly level but you know
we don't have to I'm not trying to you
know name names or out people here but
there are plenty of anchors that
literally used to work on campaigns for
for president yeah or I mean you can
name some names it looks a little weird
to me look I mean somebody like you know
there's fotopolous right ah plus there
is Diane Sawyer there's George Will I
mean even in George Will as a
commentator David Grogan he's a
commentator Donna Brazile commentator
that's different but when you're
journalists you know there are plenty of
journalists who have worked for
campaigns yeah but when you're a
commentator how different you actually
think that is so somebody like Donna
what a different day what's good but
don't you think they have a certain
amount of legions for a campaign that
they would that they worked on
previously that they you know I think
they do that's why we hire them yeah
because they not because they have
Allegiance because they have knowledge
to that person or will we will say
Donna Brazile worked for the Al Gore
campaign you everybody knows that so she
can offer insight but also we with
unless you're crazy you know that her
allegiance would be - you know - Al Gore
yeah I I think it's totally different
because when you're a commentator you're
hired
to commentate as they say or to comment
and to give your opinion as a journalist
you're not necessarily that's not your
role yeah but you're pretty much right I
would say you're right in between those
two things
um I do on CNN what I do is I do in more
of a point of view on I am hired as to
give commentary on the Tom Joyner
Morning Show radio show which had to be
approved by CNN so I feel free and
different in that zone to give but when
I'm on CNN I have to watch myself
because that's not exactly what you know
I do but everyone has a certain lens and
everyone has a certain background and
they have a point of view and I think
that's okay as a human being as long as
you let people know that and but that's
nothing new
you know Murrow Cronkite all those guys
gave commentary right well I always do
you think that's funny when you know
some of these people on TV will say well
I don't share any of my opinions and
it's like that's pretty much impossible
actually yeah but even if for no other
reason than your body language when
you're talking to somebody right now
yeah um yes absolutely yeah I don't see
anything wrong with it especially if you
declare it that's why I had you know
when people were saying Fox is to the
right okay fine they let you know MSNBC
is to the left okay fine they let you
know and we are neither here we want to
be objective at CNN but we don't want
people to run our objectivity to let
people run all over reality and truth no
yeah so I should tell everybody that
right before we started the recording
here you said to me what are we going to
talk about and I said to you that I knew
with you I wasn't going to have to you
know a lot of times I'll tell them I
guess oh we're going to touch on these
kind of things but I knew with you that
you were going to be cool with that so I
hope that that alone I want my audience
to know that because I hope that alone
will dispel some of this stuff about
sort of how a lot of you guys have to
operate or at least how you have to
operate because because the person that
I know off the camera is the same guy
that I know
right the second yeah I there you go
and then I don't want to know the exact
questions you're gonna ask me and most
of that was just like hey what are we
gonna talk about what's going on it
wasn't no you didn't you didn't push me
at all
hey don't do that or I'm gonna get mad
ya know and we don't do that with our
subjects either like someone we're gonna
go interview we don't give them the
questions I mean they'll say what are we
gonna talk about we're gonna talk about
you running for president that's the
word yeah give me uh give me like your
worst moment with a candidate like
what's like the worst thing that's ever
any real flub or did you ever really
offend anybody or anything like that no
I mean one of the UM one of the most
contentious moments was with Rand Paul
I'm sure you remember that and I started
this whole thing called no talking point
yeah cuz I hate I hate I hate talking
points and I hate the way politicians
answer questions so ask me a question
just a simple question and I'm gonna be
a politician uh done is that your office
that you're in right now well when you
talk about opposite well a grandmother
taught me was that you don't really own
anything it's all shared and it's all
part of the the American people own
everything right and then you're just
like okay are you gonna answer the damn
question yeah so the simple answer is
yes this is my office
politicians have a hard time doing that
so Rand Paul had did that with me I was
just like I'm like look man could you
stop telling me what you did yesterday
in Congress and what you did how do you
feel about this do you hear the question
that I'm asking you and so then he got
really upset we it became really heated
and so it was an uncomfortable moment
but it was also a very freeing moment to
me because I was like you know what you
know what it I'm sick of this and so I
set a marker there and so everyone I had
that came on had to answer the question
and they do now now I'm not going to
badger people because sometimes they
just won't and I'll say okay and then I
will say it is obvious that you don't
want to answer the question so we will
move on right because I don't want to
waste the audience time so that was
probably um an uncomfortable moment that
I had with a candidate but then I just
interviewed him two hours three hours
ago so it's all it's all good yeah do
you ever bite your tongue though related
to the fact that you want these guys to
come on again
because even when I was in the spin room
talking to talking to their
representatives not even the candidates
I did feel a little bit of you know I
had Huckabee's campaign on which I'm
back on there at the end of the day for
you but they all want to be on CNN fair
enough
all I gotta but yes I know where you're
going with this and the thing is it's
not it's not so let me share a little
secret with you all right this is just
between us this is just between us yeah
so if you had that concern your head and
that's a very real concern and that and
that's real because you do want people
to come back right so it's all in the
way you ask the question it's all in the
tone if I say dig why are you such a
damn bleeding-heart liberal you'll go
what do you mean so you can just go well
you know that's a very liberal
perspective why why do you feel that way
yeah it's the same question right pretty
much it's all in the way you ask it it's
like asking a question with a smile on
your face it's all in the tone and you
can do it by complimenting it's like I
know you pride yourself on your politics
and your liberalism so would you answer
this question for me it's the same thing
yeah well that's the one you asked the
question that sort of brings it back to
where we started this sort of online
verse mainstream media thing because
I'll see a lot of times you know the
online guys who aren't interviewing
these people who are just commentating
on it they'll be like lemon didn't
attack him for this or he didn't do this
or that and it's like well guess what
he's the one that actually has to stand
there do it get another interview in the
future you know figure out how to get
truth from people that aren't going to
give you a much truth so my point is
it's easier said than done here's the
thing it is it's not and it's not even
that it's easier for them to say it
because their way is not necessarily the
best way or the easiest way because you
want someone to continue to sit there in
the interview to answer questions right
and you you also want you don't want to
antagonize them and I'm also thinking
about the viewer because if I continue
to antagonize them the viewer gets no
information that person shuts down and
it's not good for any of us yeah right
so it's done so rather than what am I
going to do stand up go over to the
chair that the subject is sitting in and
wring their neck it's not it's not going
to happen so if you're if you're sitting
there Dave Rubin and you don't want to
answer
question what am I gonna do inject you
with um would you call it sodium
pentathol iam finna thaw to make you
tell the truth it's not gonna happen so
you get as much as you can and then you
move on yeah that's how it works all
right I got one more for you but first
have you ever touched wolf Blitzer's
beard I feel like I'd really actually
hit today like not in that way it was we
gave each other a TV hug and it was a
little weird like oh yeah I'm convinced
there's something there's something like
the whole secret to success is the beard
it's mad it's magic we'll be on my show
at 10:00 p.m. so you have to watch oh
nice all right cool all right well then
my my last question for you is what's
next cuz I've seen this thing not to
talk about the rise that you didn't want
to talk about before but but I've seen
it I flat out seen it so what's next man
so I'm sure you've read um what so
here's the thing people always ask me Oh
what are you gonna do next what's your
jielong I fought to get where I am so
I'm just gonna love this for a while
like I really I wake up every day and
usually you know sometimes the first
time I wake up is because an alarm goes
off and it's time for my editorial call
and the first thing that's on my mind
every day as well what am I gonna put on
TV today that is pretty freakin awesome
so I'm in a really great spot I live
every moment in gratitude I am very
happy I'm content
I'm not complacent so I'm gonna enjoy
this for the moment and I would have to
say that the next thing if I can think
about it but best laid plans right it's
probably a show that is more Bill Maher
or Chelsea Handler ish or something like
that where I can actually give a point
of view and actually say like you said
[ __ ] or whatever it is that you said
alright ah and not have everybody go oh
my gosh you can't I can't believe Don
Lemon said that right well they're
probably gonna do that either way but
yeah so that's probably if I had to
think of something but who knows I will
probably do this if all goes as it's
going now knock on wood
Oh God allow for the next 10 or 15 years
and that's not a bad thing yeah uh well
listen I a hundred percent you know how
thrilled I am for your success in our
friendship and I look forward to our
next adventure at Blondie's youyou can
down some wings you you put me to shame
I mean it was sad I had to come back I
was there this weekend past weekend yeah
I only ate eight of my ten wings oh yeah
I've ordered like to order double orders
when we've been yeah you literally you
got a double order you add I think 48
wings on a plate no I let me let me tell
you this let me tell you um I used to be
able to do that in my 20s and 30s and
40s and now I can't do it wait did you
hit the big five oh I thought over 49 I
don't want to hear it Oh No
why are you turn five oh I'm a little
behind you how far I'm 39 oh wow you're
you're older than me I'm 37 wait a
minute somethin ain't right here anyway
you guys can catch dawn weeknights on
CNN and pretty much wherever and
whenever
breaking news happens dawn thanks a lot
man thanks good to see you Dave you two
keep up the good work
you